[Music]
so part of why this is such a problem in
America right now is the cost of child
care right now it can be up to 30
percent even 38 percent of a
middle-class families salary we're
talking in New York City or New York
10,000 to 30,000 per year so if you
thinking you know Oh a middle-class
salary is between 42 and 125,000 that's
a huge chunk of anybody's earnings so
how are we gonna take care of our kids
how can we actually pay to have children
one strategy if so the people I spoke to
they just had one child or some of the
people I spoke to weren't parents yet
and they wanted to be like a school
teacher who drove uber on the side in
San Francisco and what he made what in
other places would be a middle class
salary but because of the cost of living
the cost of rent he had to take a
roommate he had to put off having a
family he was in his 40s and he had to
drive uber where he was grading papers
while he was you know at a stoplight
actually I talked to a black educator
and and someone she's they you she calls
herself indigenous other people call her
Native American and they both had
started this something called Co family
life which would mean that they're
living in collective housing with other
families with children and partially the
reason they did this was because their
parents having been working class
African Americans and indigenous people
didn't own homes due to the history of
racism so they had to instead you know
rent in expensive cities like outside
Boston so what they did was they shared
their homes with other families and
raised their kids together fed their
kids together did pick up and drop off
together none of them were involved
romantically and this went on for many
years and it's a it's a new trend called
co-parenting that I write about and
squeezed there's one way we could say oh
this is just this is bespoke and
depressing like oh we're thrown back on
ourselves we have to parent collectively
and barter and trade because our
government doesn't take care of us but
another way to think about it is it
could be revolutionary like this is a
new
family formation where you don't have to
be romantically or biologically
connected to other parents but you could
still live together in a community with
them and share you know cost of living
but also responsibility I met a bunch of
them and it was I was actually really
envious you know it's like because a lot
yeah a lot of middle-class life is
pretty isolated so I think things like
co-parenting in some ways it's tubers of
one stone because it's like there's the
isolation and then there's the economic
fragility of being middle class middle
class family so it's an economic
necessity co-parenting they'll be people
who are computer programmers who I met
or a teacher or you know other kinds of
professions like they were in a a social
worker you know they they were classic
middle-class jobs but because of the
expense of these cities and also because
of some of the isolation of being part
of a middle-class family now that you
where you might not be near your
biological family
these co-parenting formations were like
really kind of beautiful in a lot of
ways I mean I also saw the dark side
because I mean it definitely some of
those collectives didn't last you know
if it's hard
[Music]
you